foreign
[Music]
Northwest living her pre-teenage dream
yep yeah the nine-year-old joins Katy
Perry at her Vegas residency show play
for a little dance party
[Music]
when Kim Kardashians a total proud mom
documenting it all as her daughter hits
the stage with the pop star you're a
really good dancer and I thought what
better way to be a great dancer is to
show the world your awesome dance moves
it's wild so how did North get the
special VIP treatment well turns out
Katie's a big fan is that Northwest
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God North I have seen all of her
tick tocks
her new favorite thing ever
has to hang with the singer backstage
[Music]
Kim surprised North and her friends with
tickets to the concert showing up in
style on her private jet we have our
Katy Perry mocktails
you're the girl tonight Penelope
Kourtney Kardashian's daughter snagged
an invite too spending some quality time
with her cousin and Auntie Kim
[Music]
in a while it's safe to say the
California girls had a blast looks like
Kim might be the biggest Katy cat of
them all that's like the best way I know
how to describe it honestly I'm the
biggest Katy Perry fan I'm not just
saying that because you're here like
because I don't associate you
and naturally Katie asked to join the
Kardashian fam can I finally be a sister
Katie
you just gotta roll with it yeah Kim's
all for expanding her crew over the
years the mama foretold E.T how she
Revels in the joy of having a vibrant
household my house is so full but in the
best way it's amazingly full so I want
to make sure each kid gets so much of my
attention I think four is the perfect
magic number for me everyone gets along
everyone loves each other I'm rolling
with it it's just it is really Zen it
feels really equal and calm and great
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]